let me start by first seeing a few words
about russia and ukraine
i've been absolutely clear with
president putin he has no
misunderstanding if any any assembled
russian units move across the ukrainian
border that is an invasion
but it will be met with severe and
coordinated economic response that i've
discussed in detail with our allies as
well as laid out very clearly for
president putin
but there is no doubt but to be no doubt
at all that if putin makes this choice
russia will pay a heavy price
there's also not the only scenario we
need to be prepared for
russia has a long history of using
measures other than overt military
action to carry out aggression
and paramilitary tactics so-called gray
zone attacks
and actions by russian soldiers
not wearing russian uniforms remember
when they moved into the dom bus the
little green men
they weren't they were
dealing with
those who were russian sympathizers and
said russia no nobody in there
well that includes little green men in
uniforms as well as cyber attack
we we have to be ready to respond to
these as well and decisively united way
with a range of tools at our disposal
ukrainian foreign minister said this
morning he's confident of our support
and resolve and he has a right to be
now let me turn to the topic of the day
by enacting the bipartisan
infrastructure law we demonstrated the
democrats and republicans can actually
work together to get something done
and by implementing it efficiently and
effectively
we're going to demonstrate that
government also can work for people
efficiently and effectively
in just two months the investments are
underway to modernize our roads our
bridges our ports our airports
our rail delivering high-speed internet
and clean water
and expand and modernize
as i said the rail as well as
strengthening the energy grid and the
list goes on
up until now our nation has never fully
made this kind of investment
in part this reason why we've had
the whole problem with regard to supply
chains but when we start moving stuff
faster through our ports
when bridges don't have weight
restrictions when there's less traffic
on our roads because there are more
roads to travel on and people aren't
backed up bumper to bumper
and more capacity in our rails that's
how we resolve the supply chain problems
and get
goods to people
and get them to quicker quicker and
cheaper
and i know uh you've been all over the
country mr mayor uh former mayor and my
buddy
meeting with mayors and governors county
commissioners tribal leaders
and i i and like i did with the recovery
act which was a similar kind of
operation
because we need to stay on top of it i
know you remember marty as a mayor what
it was like and how detail really
matters
and so the detail matters execution
matters and i'm looking forward to an
update on where we are now and where
we're going from here so thank you very
much and i'm going to turn it over to
the
the guy who i asked to uh come out of
retirement not my retirement but come
and
take over his gigantic job for me
mr president thank you so much i'm
honored and and thank you for having me
um you asked us to rebuild america the
largest infrastructure investment in
generations in the country and this is
the team mr president that you put
together
that has been in the last 60 days uh
hitting the ground
and getting things done this is actually
the seventh meeting that we've had in
the last 60 days and each
one of these individuals has been
organizing not only their agencies but
their
partners around the country to actually
make this happen
we're actually spending a lot of time
running to the fire as we like to say
flushing out the very difficult problems
that um attended to anything that this
large that hasn't been done in a long
time
but you asked us not just to rebuild
america you asked us to rebuild a better
america and a better america
from your perspective is one uh that
we're following which means good paying
union jobs
it means using products that are made in
america so we can boost our domestic
manufacturing so that we can take the
supply chains back and grow our
independence and our safety and our
security and lower cost
for average americans it also means not
doing anything without a sense of equity
and an understanding that we can't go
forward if we can't go forward together
because diversity is this nation's
greatest strength and then uh also
thinking about the tremendous challenges
we have with climate and resilience and
sustainability to go back in a way so
that we know when bad things come we're
tough enough
to actually sustain whatever that is
uh you also said to me when i first got
here listen
the american people need to have our
trust and so therefore accountability
and transparency is important and that
we need to make sure that we work with
inspector generals and other people to
regain the public trust within all that
stuff and then finally as you have
reminded me
when you ran the recovery act downline
logistics getting it right on the ground
where it matters with people where they
live is critically important and so mr
president this is your team we're hard
at work we're ready to get the job done
and uh we're ready to continue to do the
work that we've done in the last 60 days
so thank you so
[Music]
comments much you guys
thank you
thank you